All right, munchkins.
This is the wizard welcome you back
to introduction to computer vision.
As you can tell, I'm, sort of,
energized and I've taken some time off,
about a year or two or so.
What we're going to do this time
is start working on tracking.
So the last unit or
at least some previous one, hopefully,
that depending upon the order
in which you're viewing these.
We were looking at motion which
was sort of the change in imagery
between two successive frames.
And that change could be due to a change
in viewpoint multiple cameras or
a change in time, you're watching
something move over awhile.
This unit is going to focus on tracking,
where objects are moving over time and
the computations that we're
doing are to keep track of them.
And it is sort of a fundamental
part of computer vision these days.
Although, a lot of what we're going to
be talking about will eventually get
into things that are come
from the domain of robotics.
Because there has just been a lot
of work done on sort of how you
keep track of things overtime,
we'll do a lot of modelling.
Also, I want to say again, a bunch of
slides adapted from Kristen Grauman,
Deva Ramanan and
Svetlana Laze, Lazebnik.
And I, Svetlana, if I messed
up your name, I'm, I'm sorry.